françois mitterrand nous parler de vos
lectures d'avoir parlé de l'écrivain
parce que ce n'est pas votre premier
livre ont pu bien nouveau sous le type
la paille et le grain chez flammarion
une collection capsule la rose au poing
qui dirigé par bernard pingaud et à
laquelle on trouve les textes socialiste
dont il est normal que votre livre
paraît dans cette collection
comment définir c'est dommage que c'est
une chronique dénote un journal c'est
entre la chronique elle journal
chronique forcément parce que je suis un
responsable politique j'écris de temps à
autre dans l'hebdomadaire du parti
socialiste qui s'appelle unités on me
sollicite quelquefois pour écrire les
articles dans différents journaux amis
ou adversaires et je suis donc amené à
commenter l'actualité ce sont des
chroniques et puis c'est devenu aussi un
peu un journal sans l'être tout à fait
dans la mesure où là c'est de parler
toujours de choses extérieures
j'ai quelquefois voulu m'exprimer par
les membres eux mêmes par rapport à des
faits qui ne touchent pas en vérité
universelle mais qui m'intéresse
lorsqu'il s'agit d'une promenade dans la
forêt de d'une rencontre avec des amis
d'une impression d'une sensation j'ai
mêlé les deux genres ce qui fait que
peut-être ce livre n'en a aucun en tout
cas je ne me suis pas posé en hauteur
j'ai simplement voulu en 300 pages
tenter de cerner une certaine vérité ma
position mais réaction face au monde
celui de mon pays celui aussi de
brassage des hommes sur la surface de la
planète
et puis et puis ce qui fait le prix de
la vie une série de sentiments et de
fait qui composent masi mais ce n'est
pas un journal intime et a dit je ne
sais quel journal
je ne sais quel quotidien dont se plaint
journal intime j'aurai dans ce cas là
encore beaucoup d'autres choses a dit
fièrement
mais on sent en tout cas chez vous une
sorte de besoin d'écrire un plaisir
d'écrire
j'aime écrire je pense que si je n'avais
pas été absorbé par ma vie politique
j'aurais aimé consacré partie de ma vie
à construire une oeuvre littéraire en
avait je le talent gens n'avaient en
tout cas le goût
mais ce qui m'a manqué c'est enfin si
des écrivains de grand talent il de dire
ou à ma place sans doute comment écrire
il faut l'unité de l'esprit
le téléphone qui vous déchire l'oreille
la visite impromptue
il faut l'unité de l'esprit je comprends
l'écrivain qui passent 4 5h 6h même si
ce jour-là une ariane a dit devant sa
table de travail sa page blanche il
arrivera toujours écrire quelque chose
qui corresponde à l'humain l'homme
politique ou bien celui qui est pris par
une autre profession toujours arracher à
lui-même à la peine à devenir écrivain
c'est mon cas mais est ce que léon blum
avait abandonné sa carrière littéraire
pour une carrière politique est ce que
vous pourriez inversement ou abandonné
une carrière politique à ce chien
pourquoi pas oui enfin cela dépend de
beaucoup d'éléments dans je suis pas le
seul m mais si je suis renseigné
d'ailleurs vous y fait allusion dans
votre ouvrage
gallimard attend depuis un certain temps
un livre de violence
je suis bien trop élitiste c'est une
idée qui m'a un autre sac j'ai eu après
de nombreux séjours à florence dans des
conditions je rapporte comme là au
détour d'une page et et je me suis pris
de goût pour le rendre belliciste ça m'a
valu des ennuis car une scierie de
journalistes un peu superficielle
qu'elle dit commencer par françois
mauriac qui n'était pas superficiel on
tirer de là je sais quelle comparaison à
florentin tout le monde sait qu'en
politique son retard face à machiavel il
ya qu un trop mal à bien qu'à mon avis
j'ai beaucoup combattu les affronter le
général de gaulle et le machiavel des
deux c'était lui mais en face c'est
comme ça m'a valu une certaine
réputation dont je reste au fond assez
honoré car je me suis beaucoup intéressé
à cette grande période qui est la
deuxième moitié du 15e siècle en toscane
et j'ai voulu écrire un livre sur cette
période autour de ce personnage laurent
de médicis mais comme je ne suis pas un
historien de profession
je n'ai pas su me limiter et je me suis
très vite retrouver à partir de laurent
médicis un peu plus loin un aplat de là
dessus j'ai découvert l'aragon ensuite
c'était la guerre des roses
je me suis cogné à bodio bradeurs bohème
j'ai filé sur ce camp d'herbert grande
albanie bref j'en suis la tutelle sorte
que laurent b ici ça attendra en effet
l'honneur de ma retraite
j'ajoute j'ajoute que je n'ai pas à
signer de contrat sur le rang des dix
sites été imprudent non j'ai traité avec
anima pour écrire un livre sur le coup
d'état du 2 décembre
c'est une toute autre affaire mais je
reconnais que là j'ai pris quelques
années de retard donc mon éditeur a le
droit de se place et vous avez écrit
n'est pas ce sera fait dans les mois qui
viennent vous étiez jeune homme et qu'il
poème que vous avez conservé on n'a pas
écrit oui nous mais elle s'en prenait
dans votre ouvrage vous semblez tenir
assez fun c'est bien d'ailleurs la
plupart des genres ni en poèmes dans ce
dernier passe en général et pas quand je
le dis j'ai tendance à les trouver un
peu emphatique un goût de la formule
lyrique que je trouvais original et qui
me paraît aujourd'hui incluses et cetera
bon alors je suis un critiques très
sévères pour moi même et puis de temps
en temps je suis assez content de ce que
j'ai fait une sorte de vanité d'auteur
qui ne va pas tout de même jusqu'à
risquer l'édition non et si je viens
enseignez vous avez tenu une chronique
de poésie quand vous aviez 20 ans
pourquoi je veux n'en comprenait que
c'est beaucoup dire j'ai quelquefois
oeuvre le critique littéraire et vous
est-il arrivé
ainsi connu les limites et vous est il
arrivé de séduire des dames en récitant
des vers j'ai quelquefois essayer cet
oubli bon alors votre expliqué quand
même un peu votre titre parce que ils
vont ensemble sur une parabole de la
paille on pense plutôt la parabole de la
paille et de la poutre
le grain plutôt la parabole du bon grain
de l'ivraie haïssant vous ayez une
troisième parabole c'est la paille et le
grain oui il ya aussi l'expression la
paille des mots et le grain des choses
et pourtant ce n'est pas par rapport à
cette expression que j'ai choisi ce
titre qui est comme tous les titres de
quelques livres que j'ai écrits a été
péniblement acquis par la réflexion
quand je conduis en voiture j'aime bien
comment ce que j'ai appelé ce livre
alors j'ai fini par trouver 120 et
je pense que ça dit bien ce que je veux
dire mais moi je suis d'origine paysanne
j'ai vécu toute mon enfance à la vieille
provinces françaises en saintonge et
pour moi la paille et et de grains sont
deux produits nobles aussi noble l'un
que l'autre
la paille une matière admirable et en
plus ça sert beaucoup de choses ça
servait plus encore au temps où des
machines ne croyait pas la paille au
moment de la moisson très bien et puis
le grain vient soit la peine d'insister
je vais bien vu dans la littérature de
grâce quelque chose de dense de serre et
de truffes d'où il sort nouvelle
naissance bref c'est un mot qui évoque
beaucoup de choses que beaucoup
d'auteurs ont employé avant moi alors
dans la paille et le grain disons qu'il
ya deux tiers de textes politiques ce
qui est bien normal puis un tiers qui
consacré à vos promenades à vos voyages
à la nature
vous semblez beaucoup la campagne oui
qu'il n'ait pas marqué par son enfance
surtout si elle était heureuse au
contact de deux parents de frères et de
soeurs deux cousins avec lesquels on a
passé un pacte de vie qui dure encore
soit par le souvenir ceux qui ont
disparu soit pour les vivants qui sont
les plus nombreux et puis la vie telles
que je les ai vécus qui ressemble
beaucoup plus à celles qu'on pouvait
connaître au xviiie siècle que celle que
l'on connaît déjà dans cette deuxième
moitié même qui approche de son dernier
quart du vingtième siècle
bon la campagne avec une maison ou au
sommet d'un couteau des fermes tout à
côté d une rivière touba tout à fait
classique est tout à fait banale
et puis le premier village très loin
très loin la première ville on n'y
allait pas surtout qui fait y allait au
pas du cheval n'y avait pas en fait nous
n'avions pas de l'automobile après il
est arrivé quand même je les raconte et
ailleurs une fusée et moderne qui a été
la bicyclette et qui m'a permis d'aller
de l'autre côté de la rive de l'horizon
mais
j'ai donc vécu cela en dehors des
moments j'ai les au collège angoulême
ben j'ai fait cela pleinement à 16 17
ans quand je suis arrivée à paris je me
sentais provincial content de l'être et
déchiré de perdre mes racines
alors vous aimez particulièrement les
fleurs pas seulement les roses vous êtes
un spécialiste des fleurs j'aime bien
les roses celui à des roses
je pense que les roses les français les
amis aussi finalement même quand il ya
le point qui qui les tient ce qui fait
un double symbole font assez
complémentaires le point c'est solide et
puis la rose à s'étendre
bon alors j'aime les roses mais j'aime
aussi beaucoup d'autres fleuves oui tout
presque toutes les fleurs voilà
quelques-unes qui sont stupides mais
qu'elles n'ont pas eu ce qu'on voit dans
un certain nombre de salons parisiens
tout tout raid qui n'entre au buzz
rollin dans les salons parisiens
aussi on voit que ce sont généralement
des fleurs et qui ont perdu leur sens
qui a raison et élevés dans des
conditions telles que le même plus
d'odeur et elles sont toutes pareilles
l'une des ces jeux ne pas passer mon ma
soirée avec vous a parlé des falaises
jardinage il ya beaucoup de très belles
soeurs les giroflées une fleur admirable
surtout quand ça pousse sur un mur
vertical
bon je ne devais faire l'on pense pas
généralement vie au free etc françois
mitterrand joue